hello everyone and welcome to the first
game uh
in the elimination round of the skilling
open it's magnus carlsen versus
anishigiri
and here the rules are a bit different
than in the preliminary so i'm just
gonna read what it says on the chest 24
website
so each knockout match is played uh over
two days
with two four game rapid matches at a
time control of 15 minutes for all moves
and the 10 second increment uh from move
one
uh if the matches end one to one then
two five plus three games will be played
followed if necessary by an armageddon
game where white has five minutes to
blacks for
but a draw counts as a win for black as
usual so this is the first game already
quite an interesting one
magnus with the white pieces uh let's
check it out so magnus with the white
pieces opens
with d4 and here uh if you okay we're
gonna check out
that afterwards but uh here is uh who's
playing who so magnus is facing geary
uh 11 is facing nippon issue wesley so
against rajabov and maxima srilagrav
versus
so we'll see how it goes so magnus
starts with the d4
we have knight to f6 by giri uh sorry
about that
and c4 by magnus we have
e6 knight to f3 and d5 and we have the
queen's gambit declined on the board
uh with knight c3 and now bishop to b4
there goes in defense of the of the
queen's gambit decline we have captures
captures and bishop to f4
uh knights the e for now already with a
double attack on the c3 knight gear
prepared something special for the game
and now rook to c1 adding
another defender we have knight to c6
and already
uh as of move eight we have a completely
new move as magnus plays e3
there is a game that magnus uh played
for in this position it was in 2020 this
year in the saint louis blitz tournament
against alexander grishok
uh he played knights to d2 and he was
able to win that game but here probably
thinking that geary knows about this uh
he prepared e3
and now like i said a new move in the
position and giri strikes immediately
with the g5 this is not possible
uh the the bishop has to retreat to g3
and the gear is ready with
h5 so now of course you don't want to
allow h4
to get your bishop trapped and while you
could play h3 magnus goes for h4
uh we have knight captures on g3 uh f
captures on g3 and now
g captures an h4 and now magnus doesn't
waste
time on recapturing the phone here but
rather he goes the with the immediate
bishop to b5 and now
if geary is uh well a bit greedy if he
goes for example captures then knight e5
is posing a lot of problems for geary
the c6 knight is under attack you could
you could go rook to f1 to go after the
f7 pawn uh the h5 pawn is under attack
twice so
uh it's uh it's a very uh you know it
could go either way so here instead
after bishop to be five gear he goes for
the more
uh more calm queen to d6 uh
again threatening queen captures on g3
with checks so here
we have g captures on h4 for magnus
although castling was also an option
uh queen to g3 with check and now king
to f1 saying my king is
uh perfectly fine here and now it's no
longer the knight is no longer pinned so
you have to
uh do something about your d5 pawn here
we have rook to g8 by giri threatening
to capture on g2 and now comes
rook to g1 magnus defense and now as uh
you have to keep an eye on this pawn
here that bishop captures on c3 with
rook captures on c3 and now bishop to d7
if
you capture it here then you can also
capture back with the bishop or the pawn
for that matter but at least you don't
lose the pawn
so rook to c5 magnus goes after the pawn
here everything is nicely defended
on the king side here and now a6
threatening carlson's bishop
bishop to a4 and now queen back to d6
uh and here uh we have a capture on c6
we have captures captures
and now knight to e5 and magnus has a
firm grip on the position
but guillory plays bishop to b5 with
check and here magnus goes king to e1
uh king to f2 is what the engine
recommends and it says that
the king will be very safe there and
that it's actually the way to go
uh but magnus instead goes king to e1
and he wants to
bring his king over to the queen side
where it will be very safe however
uh we have queen side castle from geary
and now you can see that uh the the
position is
rather weird uh giri is safely castled
on the queen side
uh his rook is very active his bishop is
incredibly strong
and it's still uh well it's still a
question what carlson can do with this
rook and knight here so here king to d2
he needs to
get his king to c1 and b1 but giri
doesn't allow it rook d
to e8 and now you don't have time to
move the king because uh well just
rook captures here is a threat and if
pawn captures then queen captures and c5
is coming
so here magnus needs to decide what to
do and if something like
knight to f3 just bringing back the
knight bishop c4 is incredibly strong
uh attacks the the pawn here uh but also
just uh threatens b6 which will trap the
rook and
that's that's just it you're gonna have
to give up the rook for a bishop and
then black is just
uh much better if not winning so here
after rook d to e8 we have queen
captures on h5 by magnus
now uh a lot of pressure but then again
uh it it it only works if it works
uh here gary played f6 and now the
problem is
after the knight moves the queen is
coming to g3
and there's not not a lot you can do
here uh the
and what's worse for magnus is that he's
down to 30 seconds on the clock whereas
geary has three minutes on the clock
it's not all that terrible as you do get
a 10 second increment for every move you
make but
it's still 30 seconds i mean uh if you
spend too much on one move it can it can
be deadly
and it's not like you have some free
moves in the position like to play a3 b4
without uh worrying about black doing
something just uh just to grab more time
so here at knight back to f3 by magnus
and now
queen to g3 is coming and now queen to
f2 is also
also coming you cannot play something
like moving the rook because then queen
captures here is a problem
so here magnus tried queen f5 check we
have king to b8 and now queen to f4
magnus is hoping for a queen trade uh
but giri doesn't go for it queen to f2
with
check and now king to c1 and now uh
white is in a lot of trouble here so
feel free to pause the video and win
this game for gary
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not
trading queens and not going for the
immediate rook captures on g2
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's uh bishop to e2
bishop to c4 to d3 is also fine but
bishop to e2 is just
the strongest uh white's uh why is the
best uh well first we're gonna see what
happens after rook captures on g2 the
problem with this move
is that after captures and captures
white has this annoying
knight the e1 move and now your queen is
under attack and you're not
not in time to do anything about this e3
pawn for example queen e2
attacks the knight and the e3 pawn twice
now just knights the c2 and everything
is nicely protected
uh black's gonna have to try very very
hard to prove something here although
it's uh
it's not an easy position to play
especially with white's past h pawn
so what you have to do here after king
to c1 is find bishop to e2
and now when you see it it becomes
pretty clear you're threatening to pick
up
the knight which defends the rook here
and there's not all that much uh white
can do you you don't care about queen
captures on c7 because after queen er
king to a8 there's really no move here
that uh
threatens anything for white so while
you could do it there's nothing you know
you don't gain anything but so rook to
c2 not allowing the bishop to move
because it's pinned but now comes
now comes rook captures on g2 and now
it's much different
because after captures and
[Music]
not captures and this is probably one of
the one of the things that you also
can easily overlook when calculating
such lines
with little time on the clock after real
captures you do not recapture but rather
play queen to f1 check and now it's
easily
uh you know you can spot it very easily
that it's completely winning for black
because uh but the king is getting
checkmated there's nowhere to go if
knight moves then just queen captures it
with checkmate and if you go
up the board then it's just a very nice
king hunt queen d1 check king c3
queen d3 check king to b4 now a5 with
check if king captures queen to b5 is
checkmate so you'd have to go to a4 and
now just queen b5 check king moves and
queen
to b for his checkmate so this is what
was in the position and
giri had to find it after king to c1 so
a nice
nice uh bishop to e2 just ends the game
on the spot
but as you as you saw it's not uh easy
finding that
queen to f1 check when calculating long
lines with little time on the clock
so unfortunately for geary he played
queen captures on e3 here and he went
into an end game uh trading queens which
is just
just very sad because he had a winning
position against
the world champion so here magnus was i
imagine very relieved he played capture
so we have captures and now
rook to e1 uh trading off another pair
of rooks captures captures
and now rook to g4 attacking both of the
pawns here so here
rook captures on d5 defending on d4 and
rook captures an
h4 rook to f5 going after the f pawn and
now
rook captures on d4 so magnus trades
everything down
and rook to g for now going uh well
threatening the pawn here preparing
bishop c6 to go after it
and now rook f2 adding another defender
bishop to c6 and not
knight to f3 and here of course you
don't want to capture and allow white
the past pawn but even
then i i don't think black would have
too much problems
so here bishop to d5 going after the a2
pawn and now
a3 we have b5 by black and now king to
d2 and now you can see that
there is not much you can do here if
possible somehow magnus will try to push
the
the the past g pawn but it's not going
to be easy king b7 we have knight to e5
now
attacking the rook and also giving up
the g2 pawn
because now magnus will show that this
is a dead draw because
even if you capture the pawn which giri
did the captures captures and captures
uh b4 secures a draw because your pawns
are on dark squares uh giri has a light
square bishop
and once the knight comes to d3 there
will be no
uh crossing the c5 square for the c pawn
so a5 was played we have king c3 uh
sorry king c3 captures captures here
uh and now king to b6 we have king to d4
and now everything is on dark squares
there's nothing you can do here
bishop to h3 and now knight's the d3 and
with the c5 pawn being
protected so many times uh c5 will never
be played and you can
yeah you can never lose this so a few
more moves were played
king c6 king to e5 we have bishop to g4
uh knight to c5 and now bishop to h3
knight back to b3 we have king to b6 and
now
knight back to c5 and here you can see
that there's nothing to be done
king c6 knight b3 king to b6 knight c5
and now king to c6
and it was in this position on move 50
that the players agree to a draw as
there is nothing more to be done here so
uh
a tough break for geary who had an
opportunity to take down magnus in round
one
already and take a big lead but
unfortunately he didn't spot bishop to
e2 here or or
you know c4 or d3 for that matter and
the game ended in a draw
uh so yeah that's the game i do hope you
guys enjoyed it i'm sure uh gear enjoyed
playing it but
he'd enjoy it a lot more if he actually
won it uh
we're gonna check out uh a few more
games as uh now that this game was drawn
i imagine we'll be seeing more of the
games game two is still still being
played so i don't know how that will uh
end up and we're gonna try and check out
the other the other pairs as well
uh so yeah that's the game the first
game that we're showing from the
elimination round uh i would like to
thank manoli cetinus
daniel patty uh alvis uh cadorin uh mick
battlestone and gerard houma for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual uh you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the
elimination rounds
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day